[Music]
it's when we got engaged in yosemite i
don't know i guess i'll just keep
driving
[Applause]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
some days you just gotta have cookies
for breakfast and that's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is one of my favorite
pull-offs to come to because there's a
trail that goes down to this bluff and
it's usually like really quiet and
peaceful but today it's so windy
um i was planning to talk to you guys
down there and kind of catch you up on a
few things but it is just you won't be
able to hear me you can't really hear me
in the van because i'm near the road and
cars are just whizzing by i don't know i
guess i'll just keep driving
oh my god
the sound of cars and people are
starting to drive me insane if i'm being
really honest and i know i'm one of them
so i really shouldn't complain
it's just
i really need some wide open
space and solitude right now like i'm
not hanging out with anyone i'm by
myself but i don't feel like i'm by
myself at all like this does not count
as
alone time i really truly have to be
like away from the sounds of cities and
away from cars and just like
alone alone
like desolation
i know i'm super weird but anyway we're
just gonna keep driving and exploring
[Music]
no
it's not a waste
[Music]
feeling out of place
[Music]
[Music]
think about how
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by saturnbird
because you guys know how much i love my
coffee each mini saturnburg cup is
filled with instant coffee made from
different high quality arabica beans
with numbers ranging from small to large
and the degree of roasting from light to
dark my favorite flavor is number one
always blooming and i also love these
super coffees which come in even smaller
packaging
every flavor is made of pure coffee with
no other added ingredients the coffee
dissolves instantly with ice water in
three seconds and i love that i can make
cold brew or mix things up using oat
milk almond milk or ice cream it's been
nice to have an ice cold easy prep drink
in the middle of the work day and also a
great option for those days when i'm
just in the middle of nowhere and maybe
running low on fresh ground coffee also
these empty pods stack easily so i can
set them aside with other recyclables
for the times i come across public
recycling bins
hello it is the next day so yesterday
the sun set
kind of early because it went behind a
fog bank so i lost the light early on
and
yeah heading back out to big sur today
i'm curious to see
what the weather will be like because it
said there was a fog warning
but i would imagine that would have
burned off already so let's go check it
out
[Music]
[Music]
besides costco which i do not have a
membership to this is the cheapest gas
in town elsewhere it's like five dollars
[Music]
so i don't know if i ever shared this
but i actually used to live here i lived
in pebble beach for a year and then i
lived in sand city for two years which
is right outside of monterey i was
living with my boyfriend at the time who
was in the military and we were together
for five years when we got engaged in
yosemite that
is a whole other story uh but in a
nutshell it fell apart when he relocated
to egypt and decided he wanted me to go
to egypt as well for two years and then
commit to another seven years of living
in the middle east and the east coast
which
i just i couldn't do it career-wise um
it's obviously very different living in
the middle east than it is living here
and
um i love the mountains i love my
freedom i love the open road and
yeah bottom line it just didn't work out
but i bring it up because
being back here just brings back a lot
of memories i freaking love jalapenos i
eat like one or two of these a day so oh
sometimes more
so graceful i get like red and kind of
splotchy when i eat spicy foods which
means i probably have an allergy to them
and i probably shouldn't be eating them
this is where i really first started
pursuing photography as a career
and i was working for other artists in
the area photographers and life coaches
and painters
just as their assistant like social
media assistant for the most part and i
went through a lot out here in terms of
building my career and changing my whole
life and going through
you know getting engaged and then going
through all that but this place really
inspired me to pick up my camera more
often and especially going out to
yosemite
and
yeah
whenever i was having a hard time or i
was contemplating going back to
like a
high-paying retail job um rather than
just
plugging away at this artistic endeavor
i i would go out to big sur and just
kind of watch the waves and watch the
sunset and be re-inspired and i'm just
really thankful for all the people in my
life back then that encouraged me to
keep going
because
you know like being back here
sleeping in the back of my suv
sleeping in the back of my van
you know having lived here in nice
houses it's just i wouldn't trade this
life for my old one
and that's a good feeling
when i say that i'm not talking about
the people that were in my life i'm
talking about the path that i was on i
dreamed of living on the road and
traveling full time but back then i was
just too scared to make that change fast
forward four and a half years and my
life has completely changed it isn't
always dreamy that's for sure but still
in a lot of ways i'm living what was
once just a dream let's go check out the
beach
wanna go check out the beach this is
finn back from a week-long house sit in
west seattle when the weather in
washington was still perfect
life was on cruise control hiking trails
were still accessible the views were
beautiful and i was surrounded by some
of my favorite people
then we left for europe and three weeks
went by and just like that the rainy
season had arrived
in seattle
for the first time in a long time i felt
the impact of being confined to such a
small space everything felt so dark
gloomy and
sad
i realized in that short amount of time
that when i do invest in land it
probably won't be in washington i just
don't think i'm cut out for these
winters
i swear it's been raining every single
day since i got back from europe
and i would have left the day i got back
from europe because
my van is solar powered and i eat
sunshine but
i had two friends getting married and i
just got married two days ago
so i drove to portland this morning this
is where i have my storage unit uh it's
pouring rain here and i just tried to
film and it's just as dark here like
there's just so much cloud cover and
greyness
so i don't know i have a deadline for
some projects i might have to drive to
california today
and that was completely unexpected i
thought it'd be in washington for a few
more days
but you know that's
that's life on the road
here it is this is everything i own
besides what's in my van
so this slack line i actually love slack
lining i'm not very good at it but i've
carried this around with me for three
years i've used it once when i was here
a year ago i told myself that if i
didn't use it within the next year i
needed to either sell it or put it into
storage so
i don't want to sell it i'm gonna hold
off so that when i do have a place of my
own i can set up the slackline but yeah
it's going into storage today and then i
have this hammock bug net which i've
literally never used in three years and
a second hammock because i have two and
i've only used my hammock once a hair
straightener i haven't used in two years
my mom sent me this massage gun for
christmas which is great but it doesn't
really fit in the van some extra camera
gear
i have these high heels which are i'm
kind of embarrassed to show i've i've
carried these with me for two years and
i did wear them once to a hollywood
event but otherwise i haven't used them
at all
and i'm gonna pick a couple of these
books to take out that i've already read
and replaced them with books from my
storage unit that i haven't read yet so
here are the two books i just grabbed
from storage
the selected stories of anton chekhov
i'm not sure if i pronounce that right
and baghdad express one more thing that
i want to show you guys that i'm putting
into storage because it'd be kind of
silly to keep it in the van but i'm
still really stoked about it
and i have you guys to thank for it
i got my 100 000 subscriber plaque which
is crazy because when i first started my
youtube channel
i did not expect to have this many
subscribers especially so soon
but yeah it's all thanks to you guys
thank you so much for supporting my
channel
i thought about putting it in the van
but i think that'll be a little extra so
i'm just kidding this definitely cannot
stay in the van these are my donations
this is uh this is pretty full of stuff
that i no longer need so i'm gonna head
to goodwill and then hit the road
[Music]
no overnight camping area patrolled
[Music]
is
[Music]
the central coast is kind of a difficult
place to road life mostly because of
overnight parking it's illegal to park
overnight on the pch and i don't have
the 4x4 anymore so i can't really head
into the big sur hills like i used to
which i honestly missed so much i used
to stay up there for days in the xterra
i am really lucky though since i used to
live here i have friends that offer up
driveways and i know of a few low-key
campgrounds
but yeah it'll be really good to get
back out onto some blm land and really
set up camp for now though i'm just
gonna soak up this place before heading
south
so i will see you guys out on that open
road
you